this video is sponsored by
curiositystream
many scenes in wes anderson's new film
the french dispatch have a distinct
visual rhythm
watch this shot with the addition of a
metronome running at 52 beats per minute
this visual rhythm is not a byproduct of
the music this particular scene has two
different tracks neither of which have a
tempo of 52 bpm
so this is a visible rhythm that is
distinct from the tempo of the music and
the dialogue
throughout this same scene we can see
that many edits or major actions fall
roughly on beat with the metronome
this distinct visual rhythm is another
example of the kind of stylistic choice
i examined in my previous video about
wes's style
in that video i highlight a handful of
major quirks in his style and the role
they play in drawing the audience's
attention to the act of storytelling
itself
music and skill champion statue
the french dispatch accomplished
something that seemed impossible to me
after the grand budapest hotel it
heightened west's already unique style
even further so let's look at some of
those stylistic elements that make the
french dispatch tick
here's another example of a scene with a
visual tempo
this time the scene feels like it runs
roughly at 42 beats per minute instead
of having action that feels fluid and
natural it's broken up into distinct
cues these can be a character turning
starting or stopping a movement a glance
or facial expression
an edit a camera movement starting or
stopping a character entering or leaving
the frame or some other kind of action
that has visual prominence
these cues are emphasized visually by
the unnaturally stiff poses of the
characters in the scene that aren't
executing one of these beats of action
in this scene the movement of the camera
starts on one beat the stall owner and
pedestrian start moving on another and
the cyclist and car on a third beat all
of these happen as distinct beats and
those beats are arranged to follow a
tempo back it up a little bit and we can
see how even this motorcycle pulling
around the corner feels in sync with the
pedestrian turning around i want to be
clear adherence to this tempo is more
jazz than electronic drum machine and i
doubt the scenes are actually executed
using a metronome but in the same way
musicians work together to keep the time
in a song i think wes is having his
actors extras and camera operators work
together to roughly keep the time of the
scene something which is then reinforced
in editing once a rhythm is established
west can change it or break it to match
shifts in emotion or for comedic effect
yes it is
no it isn't yes it is noise yes it is no
it is it is yes it is all artists sell
all their work it's what makes you an
artist selling it it's pretty astounding
how intricate this choreography is often
the turn of an actor's head or the
glance of their eyes is precisely timed
and there are shots like this one where
even this extras barely perceptible
blink is in time with the start of the
shot and the beat of the camera moving
this is a technique wes has used in the
past but he adheres to it more formally
in this film than ever before
in addition to the strict choreography
of the action he also heightens his
style by using other methods to abstract
elements of the story even more than he
normally would in the grand budapest
hotel wes would occasionally shift into
a visually absurd space but the
stylization still happened mostly in set
design choreography and performance the
action of that film still felt like it
was taking place in a physically real
space with real people walking through
it for the most part in the french
dispatch the action becomes more
abstract characters frequently stare
directly into the camera are frozen in
time or in a pose sometimes only a few
frozen as if they're posing for a
photograph while the rest of the world
moves around them
the geography of the set sometimes
doesn't make sense this depiction of
this room and this depiction don't line
up spatially from shot to shot
and then suddenly in a spike of
intensity the film will slip into
momentary naturalism complete with
handheld camera work
only to snap back to its stiff
abstraction moments later
lighting changes dramatically around the
characters characters speak to each
other in different languages without
translation wes mixes miniature and live
action photography in the same shots he
uses stop motion and 2d animation
wherever it suits him lights exterior
locations to make them look even more
like sets switches frequently between
black and white and color photography
and often changes aspect ratio even for
a single shot within a scene all of this
pushes the film towards a point of
almost absurd surrealism but does it
have a purpose
wes is clearly having fun and doing
things his own way but is that all he's
doing or does drawing our attention back
to artifice style and the act of
storytelling actually serve a purpose in
this story
his writers line the spines of every
good american library
the film is a very thinly disguised
tribute to the new yorker a magazine wes
anderson has collected and been obsessed
with since childhood not only is arthur
howitzer jr the editor of the fictional
magazine played by bill murray based on
elements from actual editors at the new
yorker but anderson draws heavy
inspiration from specific articles from
the magazine and the style of the
writers who wrote them i've already
written a thousand words take for
example the middle story which is almost
a direct adaptation of parts of mavis
gallant's article the events in may a
paris notebook part 1. the events
depicted in this story mirror some of
those accounted in the article the
touching narcissism of the young but
kremens herself is clearly modeled after
gallant in certain ways her writing
style is borrowed from gland attack in a
kind of frenzy that seems insane the
courage of these kids don't get too near
impossible to imagine these students
exhilarated naive brave in the extreme
returning to their obedient classrooms
and she behaves similarly in the story
both have a detached sense of interest
in the movements and both get themselves
embroiled in the actual events seemingly
beyond their better judgment but the
interesting element is that the story
here in the film and in each of these
three main stories is not just an
adaptation of the inspiring material
they are also stories about the writers
themselves furthermore they aren't just
stories about these storytellers but
stories about how those storytellers
tell their stories
arthur howitzer jr the editor of the
french dispatch tells his writers try to
make it sound like you wrote it that way
on purpose the writers that wes has
chosen as inspiration often mashing
several together into one character are
without fail all people who had a unique
style and approach to writing in the
interview introducing the book an
editor's burial which collects many of
the articles the film is based on wes
says
when you're making a movie you want to
feel like you can take it in any
direction you can experiment as long as
it in the end feels like this is what
it's meant to be and has some authority
when watching an art lecture from
roseman bernier the character berenson
in part is based on as all of you
remember cezanne said of money money is
just an eye but what an eye
widely celebrated as you know
for the bold dramatic style and colossal
scale of his middle period or when
reading james baldwin's essay equal in
paris which roebuck writes story draws
inspiration from
what they were writing about is
interesting but it's also the way they
wrote or spoke the confidence of their
authorial voice the casual intensity of
bernier the staccato rhythm of gallant
or the parenthetical eloquence of james
baldwin each of these writers wrote in a
unique way but they wrote in a way that
felt completely and entirely their own
their writing uses rhythm tangents
shifts in perspective abstraction and
all other manner of poetic and stylistic
license it's a designation that i'd have
no trouble applying to wes anderson's
own work and perhaps these writers were
in part the influences that gave him the
confidence to work in a way that was so
entirely his own the french dispatch
celebrates the joy of stylistic excess
of having fun with storytelling and
showcasing your creative personality
even in the midst of telling serious
stories poetic not necessarily in a bad
way oh while the film itself does these
things the film stylistically is an
expression of the unique voices of each
writer and their playfulness with style
and tone the film exists in a surrealist
space but unlike many forms of
surrealist filmmaking not a dream like
one instead it's an imaginative one
almost as if the film exists in the
minds of the writers writing the stories
or in anderson's as he reads them and so
the film visually comes to life not as
an attempt to translate its source
material into realism and then depict
that as many film adaptations of writing
do but it brings the prose it mimics to
life in a way that reflects the joy of
poetic license
shots like this are not just poetic in
how they're written but in how the scene
is visually constructed and
choreographed writing has a flexibility
to shift perspective skip definitely
through time freeze time and examine a
moment shift in style and tone and
create abstraction and film shares all
these possibilities but normal
conventions of filmmaking don't
generally allow for them to be employed
or if they are it's generally one or two
not everything in the kitchen sink
tossed into a single film but if you're
going to do that what better place to do
it than in a film about a magazine that
allowed its writers to flex their
stylistic muscles and to be totally
themselves as artists you see the girl
on it no
trust me she's there when we reduce how
we think about films or any art merely
to the content to what it exposes we can
lose out on the pleasure they can hold
in other ways the beauty of a shot or
how a scene is constructed sometimes is
in my opinion enough the point is he
could paint this beautifully if he
wanted but he thinks this was better i
think i sort of agree with him
sometimes the rhyme and rhythm of a poem
is enjoyable even when you don't
understand what it means
and not all music needs lyrics
in the french dispatch within each story
there are moments where the black and
white photography erupts into color
these shifts delineate time helping keep
separate the film's many parentheticals
and shifts in perspective but they also
help illuminate what i think was most
vivid for each storyteller in their
story for berenson it was the art itself
for crements it was the youth for
roebuck wright it was the food and
within the larger story not the articles
within but within the french dispatch
the film what's rendered in color is
what is most vivid for wes anderson the
storyteller
the writers in the act of storytelling
are what's portrayed in color it's easy
to imagine howitzer junior's advice
applying to wes's own films however you
do things just try to make it seem like
you shot it that way on purpose the
documentary obit about obituary writers
at the new york times is a great
documentary companion piece to the
french dispatch the guy who runs the
times clip archive even seems like he
could be a character out of a wes
anderson film you can watch this
documentary which i love right now on
curiosity stream which has thousands of
educational and documentary titles and
when you sign up for curiosity stream
you'll also get access to nebula a
streaming service built and owned by
creators like myself you'll get bonus
videos from me as well as all the new
videos from myself and other great
nebula creators early and ad-free this
bundle is an amazing deal for less than
fifteen dollars for an entire year
you'll get access to two streaming
services full of great content nebula
has a roku app and an ios app now so
when you sign up you can watch videos
from me jacob geller like stories of old
patrick h willems and many others early
without any ads or sponsorship you'll
get that and all the great documentary
content on curiosity stream for less
than fifteen dollars for a year when you
sign up for the bundle today click the
link on the screen or in the description
to sign up right now and watch obit
[Music]
you